[Music]
on the dish this morning gezina Bullock
Prado the pastry chef author and former
Hollywood player sister of Sandra
Bullock who many years ago moved to
Vermont and never looked back Bullock
prado's latest book is called my Vermont
Table recipes for all six seasons yes in
Vermont there are six seasons we'll
explain
look at these gorgeous look at this this
is maple sugar now you just want to dive
into that and play with it and smush it
around what you're going to do put that
in there and smush it if you don't know
how to bake call in the expert see you
you got a nice Pace going there see you
want it Pasty
kind of like me after a long winter
which is how our day started with gezina
Bullock Prado what are we making by the
way we're making Maple tweel which is
one of the yummiest cookies okay ever
okay so you're gonna take
a dollop
put it here
and you're just going to smear it
down
a little a little thinner
and here's a trick if you use the whole
of the spatula and smearing
beautiful slime so next we're going to
go into the oven but you have to be
Jeffy on the spot with this you cannot
leave the oven alone Jeffy on the spot
you have to be Jeffy on the spot okay
okay
the batter sits in the oven until it
begins to Brown and bubble which at 400
degrees only takes a couple minutes
you're going to take it and just flip
that little bit over before they're
rolled into cylinders that is not bad
that is Pretty stinking great and for
the first time
genius so this was completely cool
wanna try one they're so good
[Music]
I've made you a baker does anybody want
to try my schmear
what is it called Dingle oh my God
wait what's it called again a tweel a
tweel it's similar
Bullock prado's path to cooking stardom
started in Virginia where she was raised
a strict vegan orders of her mom I was
full of Rage I was full of Rage mainly
because my lunch is really stunk my mom
made her own like crumbly bread I would
have a vegan spread on it and it was
just it was just sadness in a Ziploc
eventually she moved to Los Angeles
where she worked alongside her sister
Sandra and co-produced films including
gun shy and Miss Congeniality too what
was it about the West Coast that didn't
work for you
well it wasn't Vermont
what is it about
there is a coziness a safety it is truly
such a comforting and beautiful place
and so is the food a collection of that
food is now featured in her latest book
called my Vermont Table recipes for all
six seasons if you think about the
winter in Vermont it's just an
incredibly long season so you kind of
it's nice to break it up right so right
before winter and the snow comes you get
stick season because most people think
fall lasts forever here it's like a week
after winter comes mud season when the
snow is melted into the ground
and the maple trees start to show signs
of life and that's just right before
spring and when things are you know kind
of ooky outside but vermonters love it
because we know it's coming we know the
Sap's starting to run
on this Vermont table ribbon salad
arugula radish broad beans zucchini and
squash with goat cheese
homemade sourdough bread
obasa a Bavarian spread with Camembert
cheddar and paprika
chicken salad
spaetzel a bit dumpling a bit pasta
and beef wellington which Bullock Prado
prepares sous-vide oh this is so tender
it's falling apart oh
and I have a little piece I felt the
weight of it
it's a nice little piece of meat and
wellingtons are one of those things that
people really freak out about making
because you are essentially cooking meat
blind right
it's one of my favorite things
the Suites included a strawberry
chocolate mousse cake and maple glazed
donuts it looks so good it almost looks
fake Donuts are never fake Donuts are
one of the realest things ever
and they don't talk back wow heading to
the syrup syrup this way
for the final desserts
we just had to run out for some
ingredients
so about an
Amazon
so junk but gentle tabs exactly right
there
until it feels really snug
I think that looks good
let's see if it's coming yes now attach
that bucket let's get all that sap
oh yeah uh-huh
and there it goes
it's like not the sweetest
no so it takes 40 gallons of this to
make one gallon of the syrup
that's why it's so special yeah and so
sweet and great because it takes time it
takes time and love and love and dingles
the Dingle will live forever
the end results
Simplicity itself
maple syrup and snow
as pure as it gets you need the maple
already made and you boil it down to 235
then you call your dentist
and make an appointment
what's better
isn't it fantastic it's like taffy
it's Tree Taffy
if people want to understand Vermont
food
what do you tell them it's
kind of authenticity it's Joy it's
Comfort a lot of people think it would
be very heavy but it's incredibly
seasonal it's truly the OG Farm to Table
food
she was so great as Marcy said I want
her to be my best friend yeah oh without
a doubt um we had a lot of fun we had so
this morning we have some of her Vermont
style which which smells so good I can
smell right now
with the um obasa spread this is the
Camembert she didn't send the Dingle the
Dingle did not make it Jeffrey Todd I'm
sorry I forgot what I'm not close I
don't mind
they're very similar no they're not they
share a lot of letters
um and that is what I tapped right there
you tapped this you tap that oh yeah and
six seasons I like that as well